good morning it gets too thick given
that the quadriga con was a tie I
suppose that we're going to have to do
it with Dragon Con again in 2016 so I
already started training but
unfortunately during my first training
session I pulled my hamstring I wish
that were a joke but you can probably
tell from the way that I'm walking that
it's not anyway I'm gonna become someone
else today okay I'm here on the crash
course government said so hey guys you
know Sarah and I have a show with PBS
Digital called the art assignment where
we go around the country and we talk to
contemporary artists and then give you
an art assignment one of those
assignments Tameka Norris has become
someone else's really stuck with me so I
want to try it today and I invited my
friend and our office manager zulay up
longtime nerdfighter
to join and also become someone else
yeah so the idea to like change one
thing about your physical appearance and
then take them before selfie and an
after selfie of like who you become in
that process yeah she's gonna cheat but
I'm gonna play by the rules because
that's who I am as a person okay so
first things first let's take her before
so these your current you right now yep
and then I'm gonna be current me Sophie
interlude music because people on
YouTube really hate something when
skiing I'm gonna change from my everyday
regular clothing that I read whatever
western clothing that is to traditional
clothing that people like my mom wear
everyday people think because I have
respect for people like that and do you
feel self-conscious when you wear hijab
in public no could you just it's just
part of yeah how you've always dressed
so I'm much more self-conscious than you
I get recognized a lot when I go out and
it makes me anxious it's not bad like
I'm grateful to people for coming up to
me and everything but it's mostly what's
weird is this women like people just
like take pictures from a distance I can
feel them looking at me and I'm very
nostalgic for some reason about like
2007 to 2009 when everyone I would meet
on the street were like nerdfighters and
it's terrible to be nostalgic for that
time because of course in the years
since many things that I like have
happened like I have had children whom I
am quite fond of and like my book became
very successful and became a movie and
stuff but anyway I still kind of like to
be
come 2008 me and you know how I do that
zoo ayo by putting on ad that's right I
put on a hat we my good coffee just fall
away sober tamika's instructions we are
now going somewhere
dressed as our new selves how do you
feel kind of the same
we forgot money so zoom is trying to
download the Starbucks app so our trip
to Starbucks was completely unsuccessful
however we did go out in public and talk
to strangers as someone other than
ourselves right what was your experience
maybe I'm just more comfortable wearing
this kind of clothing that I thought I
was and I should do it every day yeah
selfie in a mood music how did your hat
make you feel wearing that doesn't make
me feel like someone else and someone
I'm more comfortable being in public so
it's strangely effective selfie
interlude music pick what I love about
the art of Simon is that makes me do and
think about things I wouldn't usually do
or think about in this case it made me
think about what's changed and what
hasn't in the last few years I think I
think some kind of loss is inherent to
change but doing to make his assignment
reminded me that I am always becoming
someone else so thank you to Tameka
Norris check out the art assignment
there are lots of great assignments and
lots of great videos about contemporary
art I think I wonder if you had to
become someone else who you'd become
I'll see you on Friday
oh wait PS the wonderful people at
penguin UK are doing an awesome project
to raise money for the Teenage Cancer
Trust it's got a Fault in Our Stars
theme so if you live in the UK or
Ireland please check out Knight of
infinities Co UK thanks bye